biden's race to the bottom that's the
focus
of tonight's angle
a long long time ago joe biden was
against using executive orders to ram
through
what is properly left to the legislature
some of my republican friends and some
of my democratic friends even
occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator we're democracy
we need consensus well the dictator
threw that
idea out the window because of course
the bind brigade
has a country to remake and redeem
so today he continued taking a wrecking
ball to his
unity goal the man who served up as
you know he was the vp to the two-term
african-american president
he's tripled down on the negative view
that america
at her core is racist
our soul will be troubled as long as
systemic racism is allowed to persist
we can't eliminate it it's not gonna be
overnight we can't eliminate everything
but it's corrosive it's destructive and
it's costly
now to address the aforementioned
systemic racism
biden signed a slew of executive actions
today
including barring the doj from
contracting with private prisons
ending what he calls racially
discriminatory federal housing policies
and addressing anti-asian bias
including references to the covet 19
pandemic by the geographic location
of its origin now according to biden
you're a racist if you call it the wuhan
virus understand write that down
now if you believe america is hopelessly
racist it's an
irredeemable place something must be
wrong with her
evil founders thus biden had to
officially renounce
any prior efforts to establish patriotic
education
and eliminate trump's race-blind
approach
to workplace training i rescinded the
previous administration's harmful ban on
diversity and sensitivity training
and abolish the offensive counter
factual 1776 commission
unity and healing must begin with
understanding and truth
not ignorance and lies does he even know
what he's reading
i mean you have to understand this a
discussion
of the wonders of the american founding
is now
i guess he said the words in biden's
view a lie
so if you now believe what most of us
were taught in school that our founding
fathers were brilliant heroic men no
one's perfect
they made mistakes they all had flaws
some big flaws
but if you thought they were brilliant
heroic man
you're ignorant and if you praise the
wisdom of the framers
you're a liar and probably a racist
does biden now renounce then his own
catholic education
his teachers his professors
who celebrated for instance the
declaration of independence and the
constitution
as well as the men who signed them the
1776 commission
understood that america is a great
nation that nevertheless
made some grave errors today's left
inverts that belief insisting that we're
a gravely
evil nation that only occasionally does
some good things
like elect obama in biden
we've never fully lived up to the
founding principles of this nation
state the obvious that all people are
created equal and have a right to be
treated equally throughout their lives
you know we've uh we've bought the view
that america is
a zero-sum game in many cases
it is a wonder that hundreds of
thousands of people apply to become
american citizens
every year from all corners of the earth
now i've had the privilege of getting to
know many of these hard-working and
grateful new americans
and they're from everywhere from africa
central america
beyond at times it seems right that they
understand more about the goodness the
promise
and the opportunities of america than
the vengeful
native-born leftists churning out
race-based executive orders for biden
so you have to ask yourself how did we
get here
well for decades radical academics have
been teaching students
to believe that white privilege is a
greater threat to us
than the ccp islamic terror
the former soviet union unemployment and
certainly any virus
and now giddy with a compliant biden in
the white house
they now want those who disagree to be
shamed
re-educated and in the case of trump
supporters
purged completely from society i am not
exaggerating that
there will be no end to the demands of
these racial rabble rousers i'm talking
hundreds of billions if not trillions in
new spending
they believe that dangling the prospect
of reparations
will obscure the fact that their
policies just
just to name a few open borders and the
offshoring of jobs
will make impoverished and working-class
americans of all races
poorer and left safe but never fear
the woman who lied repeatedly about
benghazi
will right all wrongs by assuming that
if you're white
and you succeeded at something it must
be because you rob someone else of a
more deserving
opportunity every agency will place
equity
at the core of their public engagement
their policy design and program delivery
to ensure that government resources are
reaching americans
of color and all marginalized
communities
rural urban disabled lgbtq plus
religious minorities and so many others
now apparently america is so rigged
that susan rice attended two of the
country's most
elite institutions right here in
washington dc
the national cathedral school and then
on to stanford university
acceptance at stanford university stands
at about
four percent now compare that to someone
like shelby steele
a current fellow at stanford's hoover
institution who said this on our show
last week
his white guilt is still an animating
force in american life
and it won't ever we won't ever get
beyond it
until white america begins to feel to
lose its insecurity
around race yes we we
we did horrible things but today america
is
remarkably free of racism if you're a
black person in america today you are
not your life is not going to be stunted
by racial persecution
now if what rice and the rest of the
biden team are claiming is true
then why should we ask anyone here to
sacrifice for this country
for instance in the military as a member
of a police force
frankly any public service now
why did susan rice as national security
advisor sign
on to sending our troops abroad to die
for this country
why would a rotten racist evil country
be worth defending
why would we want our systemically
racist values to be exported abroad
now let's face it the democrats know all
too well that
trump grew his political support among
all minorities especially
latinos and asians why did he do this
because his policies delivered record
low in
unemployment for blacks and hispanics
household income grew for all races
and ethnicities but the left has never
been serious about growing the economy
has it
biden has already killed thousands of
good paying jobs with his attack on our
energy sector
nice going joe soon companies are going
to be moving once again
jobs back to china and other countries
to avoid his smothering regulations and
crippling taxes
but biden's handlers think they can
still keep minority voters on the hook
with identity politics virtue signaling
diversity quotas and the pipe dream of
reparations
it's so cynical and more than that it's
so insulting
like biden's purported disdain for
executive orders
this is all a fraud it's a cruel hoax
it's cruel both to minorities and to the
overwhelmingly
good people who make up our american
family
we on the laura ingraham well it keeps
on laura ingramshow the ingram angle
we're going to continue to answer their
twisted and poisonous claims
and we'll do it with facts love
patriotism and sometimes yes because
unlike them
we haven't given up on america and
that's the angle